according to the cdc
as of last thursday
182 and a half million americans 55 of
the country
have been fully vaccinated against the
wu flu but according to dr fauci
only 2.8 million americans
0.85 percent of the country have been
fully vaccinated against the wuflu
because according to dr fauci as he
recently told the atlantic magazine it
is likely
for a real complete regimen that you
would need at least a third dose end
quote
at least
do you see how this ends
it doesn't it just goes on and on and on
and all the while
big tech will censor more and more of
what we would say about the virus and
the vaccines
and the lockdowns
even when we are directly quoting the
public health authorities i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
coming yesterday from intergalactic
transmitter who says facts are in
violation of youtube's policy that's
true that's not even hyperbole or a
conservative talking point youtube is
now censoring facts youtube is now
censoring me from quoting the director
of the cdc it's not just youtube but
i've been beating up on youtube the last
couple days it's facebook two makes you
want to protect your data makes you want
to protect
your identity and and when you want to
do that i would strongly recommend
lifelock i know what you're thinking you
are thinking
that
the only people who are at risk of
getting hacked or having their identity
stolen on the internet they're just
celebrities they're just very well-known
people
everyone's after your data okay payment
apps like venmo cash app apps that you
use all the time
you might want to adjust your privacy
settings because a recent report found
that those payment apps share user data
with third parties such as banks fraud
monitoring services some even share it
with marketing firms it's very important
to understand how cyber crime and
identity theft are affecting our lives
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats like your social
security number for sale on the dark web
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions but you can
keep what's yours with lifelock by
norton join now save up to 25 off your
first year at lifelock.com slash knowles
canadawles that's lifelock.com
knowles canon wles for 25
off head on over to lifelock.com knowles
i joked yesterday on the show
that i might not be allowed to quote the
director of the cdc
because
quoting the director of the cdc what she
had to say about the virus and the
vaccines was actually in violation of
youtube's new policy against medical
misinformation
so i was sort of half joking about this
i i deep down i thought no i think i'm
allowed to quote the director of the cdc
right there's no way that facebook could
send youtube rather and facebook could
censor me for that
and then i was told this is not a joke i
was told after my show
buy
my social media team here
that i actually
i actually was not allowed to quote the
director of the cdc that would be in
direct violation of the youtube policy
and it could it could get this channel
taken down for at least a week if not
longer
so i thought well that's
that's really something else that's
really a strange state of thing so i i
insisted
if we are going to be censored by
youtube i want to make it clear i want
to tell you what is going on because
youtube is not the only place that you
can get this show i know a lot of people
watch it on youtube a lot of people
watch it on facebook if you go to the
michael knowles show podcast you can
subscribe for free at apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play you can
get the full uncensored version of the
show
uh we're we're going to make clear when
we when we are not allowed to say things
like quoting the director of the cdc uh
on all of the platforms but if you want
the full thing you can you can go get
the free version apple podcast spotify
stitcher all that and you can go
subscribe to the daily wire where you
get the full video version
uh for free uncensored
uncut or you're gonna get you're gonna
get the real deal all that really
raunchy stuff like when we quote dr
rochelle wallensky the director of cdc
you know what
we're hearing now
is that
well what we're hearing from the
scientists is different than what we're
hearing from youtube but what we're
hearing from youtube is the vaccine
is totally a hundred percent effective
at stopping it's a it prevents the
spread of covid19 right but we're also
not allowed to say that anything totally
prevents govid19 so we're really between
a rock and a hard place here what we are
told though because obviously we all
know people who have been vaccinated and
gotten covet 19 we see it on the news we
see it from the from the public health
experts and what they say is well that's
just a breakthrough case
yeah
you don't say that by definition it's a
breakthrough case if you're telling us
that
that if you can't get covid19 if you
have the vaccine and then someone does
get covered 19 they'll say well it's a
breakthrough yeah right by definition
but there seem to be a lot of
breakthrough cases don't there and by
the way a lot of these breakthrough
cases are not are not really being
reported a friend of mine a colleague of
mine his wife was
had one of these breakthrough cases she
came down with covid19 she was ill from
it she then had longer-term effects even
after she was vaccinated she went to the
hospital they've diagnosed her with some
problems associated with covid19 and my
friend asked the doctor
will this be classified as a
breakthrough case for covet19 and the
doctor said probably not because by the
time you took her to the hospital with
these later on developed symptoms she
was testing negative so that probably
won't be so the question is one how many
people are breakthrough cases that are
not being counted and two
how many breakthrough cases do there
need to be before we start to question
before we're even allowed to question
the efficacy of the barrier through
which the cases are breaking
if you ask the scientists they're
they're going to be a little more honest
about this i think than big tech which
is not permitting you
to question that sort of thing the
propaganda's gotten really
really crazy
here's a story that i think really sums
it up
story just came out yesterday i think
right yeah from the associated press
woman who survived spanish flu
and world war
dies at 105 after contracting covet 19.
darn you kovid
ah kovid i can't but this woman survived
so much she survived a an epidemic that
occurred
uh more than a century ago
she survived a world war
but she couldn't survive covet 19.
gosh she might have lived to 106.
or
how old is she going to live i was the
oldest person ever reportedly lived to
what like 119 or so she still had a lot
of good years left in her i don't mean
to make light of this woman's death
she lived a good long life okay
very few of us are going to make it to
105.
all right that but it's covid19 let's
not forget that the average age of a
covid death is higher
in the united states for a lot of the
pandemic than the the life expectancy in
the united states
so um by the way that doesn't mean that
okay if you live longer than the life
expectancy see your life doesn't matter
but it is a little bit different than
other epidemics
where the average age of someone who's
dying from is significantly lower okay
it just it does put these things into
perspective i had one friend who died of
of covid19 he was a former teacher of
mine
he was 97 years old about he was weeks
away from turning 98.
did he die from covid19
like maybe so i guess technically maybe
he did or did he die because he was
almost 98 years old
it's a little bit different it's a
little bit different okay but we're not
allowed to say that because
the people who are
demagoguing this
want to pretend on the one hand
that every single death that has in any
way any sort of connection to covet 19
is a covid death right you contract
covenant 19 you get shot in the head in
the streets of chicago that is a covet
death right that you and you actually
did see examples of this
especially last year so they want to
pretend that on the one hand they also
want to pretend that any infection is
tantamount to death the infection the
infection rates are rising in florida so
what who cares what are the
hospitalization rates what are the death
rates
how do they compare to the
hospitalization death rates throughout
the epidemic in california or in new
york
what's the survival rate of the
coronavirus for the vast vast fast vast
majority of people
they face an infinitesimally small risk
of death from covet
you see this play out in other areas
okay i'm not even
covid in and of itself is a frustrating
political issue the way it's being
exploited but
the reason i even mention it is is to
show
that
these issues are not so much about the
facts
as they are about the framing
okay it's a it's the framing is the real
issue here and you see you see it forget
about copenhagen for a second you see it
with guns right guns it's one of these
issues that the left has demagogued
forever and now they're saying you know
there's an increase in violence we need
to stop guns guns are the problem we
especially assault weapons it's the
assault weapons if we just ban those
come on it's common sense we've got to
ban the assault weapons then we won't
have issues with violence in america
anymore
so the fbi the uniform crime report from
the fbi just came out on monday it shows
you how many people were killed in 2020
with these various sorts of weapons
how many people were killed twice as
many people in 2020 in the united states
were killed with knives then were killed
with shotguns
and rifles including the dread assault
weapons the ar-15s and all the other
kinds of rifles
combined
all the people killed with shotguns all
the people killed with hunting rifles
all the people killed with
ar-15s all the people killed with all
the other kinds of rifles
half
half the number as the number of people
killed by knives
the fbi report show so by the way the
numbers are important here 203 people
were killed with shotguns in 2021 454
were killed with any kind of rifle it's
a total of 657 deaths
1732 people were killed with knives or
cutting instruments
there are also many more people being
killed by hands and feet and clubs and
hammers and all sorts of things but
we're not talking about
banning those sorts of weapons
the reason that you're not hearing about
knives or banning these you know these
these lethal weapons these two fists i
had to register with the government
the reason that we're not talking about
that is it it doesn't frame the issue
quite so well
it's not that the left is after reducing
violence the left is after taking away
your guns because that's a civil right
it's not that the left is after
preventing you ever from getting germs
or getting sick again it's that the left
is after taking your power taking away
your rights your right to go to church
you're right to work your right to have
election integrity measures in place the
left is after that and they're willing
to use whatever they can find to justify
that
including prolonging the the
worst pandemic in the history of the
world at infinitum 15 days to 580 days
to now probably going to go on forever
if we let that happen
speaking of absurd framing
a woman testified yesterday over on
capitol hill
about abortion in the united states and
the way abortion used to be framed in
the way old days of i don't know 60 70
years ago is that it's an evil evil act
that no one would even speak about
right that it's it's killing a baby it's
obviously a very evil act
then starting about i don't know 50
years ago or so
abortion began to be spoken of as some
kind of right but a tragic right you
know a right that people don't ever want
to use but we have but women need to
have that right this was largely because
of second wave feminism which said that
women need a man like a fish need a
bicycle and
that women and men are exactly the same
but you know they have this big
difference which is women
conceive and carry and give birth to
children and so this is a
real impediment if uh women and men want
to have the exact same relationship to
sex and want to be able to walk away
from casual sex so therefore women need
to have the right to kill their babies
that was that was the argument of the
second way feminists but but even as
recently as 2008 even a little bit later
you had presidential candidates hillary
clinton saying that abortion should be
safe and legal but it should be rare
because it's bad it's a really bad thing
and it's tragic and so it should be safe
and legal and rare now that framing has
gone too now abortion is being called
an act of love
sba has not only caused a near total
abortion ban in texas it has made it
extremely dangerous to be pregnant in
texas
where our maternal morbidity and
mortality rate is already unconscionably
high especially for black women and
pregnant people of color
texas deserves better
i know firsthand that abortion saves
lives for the thousands of people i've
cared for abortion is a blessing
abortion is an act of love abortion is
freedom
we need federal protection now we need
laws that elevate science and evidence
and recognize the dignity and autonomy
of people accessing care abortion is
love
abortion is blessing abortion is freedom
war is peace freedom is slavery
ignorance
is strength
this
abortion is a sin and it's a very grave
sin
it's not an unforgivable sin but but it
is it is a it is a grave sin
and if you repent of it then
you're on you're getting on the right
track
what this woman is doing is
is worse
because she's not only defending
abortion
she is blaspheming she is committing
real sacrilege a real heresy here
she is
inverting the moral order calling it a
great blessing an act of love a godly i
mean that's what you're saying it's a
godly act right it's a blessing where do
blessings come from they come from god
abortion is love well god god is love
right we hear this in the scripture
she's she's equating abortion with
godliness with god himself that is some
really sick stuff
okay
it is probably
the inevitable consequence of a
political regime that tolerates abortion
is there's just this cognitive
dissonance right the safe legal and rare
thing you just can't hold it forever if
it's murder it shouldn't be legal if
it's if it's not murder if it's just
getting your appendix taken out then it
shouldn't be rare and so eventually that
tension is going to have to resolve
itself one way or the other and the way
the left has resolved it is that it's a
wonderful good thing and this comes from
the right actually has some
responsibility in this because the right
has adopted a lot of the liberal
language of maximizing individual
autonomy and bad choice and you do you
and i'll do me and i would never impose
my views on you and you don't impose
your views on me which is preposterous
that's never existed that is not
possible in a self-government the whole
point of self-government is we persuade
one another of the way we view the world
and then we create laws in accordance
with that so
that was never going to work the right
largely seated the battlefield the left
took over
and now they call abortion a blessing
woe to those who call good evil and evil
good
but that that is the framing that we're
living under
she even snuck transgenderism in there
she said
that uh she's referring to uh women and
pregnant people of color that's even you
know even that ability to claim
victimhood very very important here
abortion saves lives
[Music]
the one thing first of all no woman
has any medical condition that is cured
by abortion
okay it's not that the there can there
are
there's really just one medical
condition an ectopic pregnancy where the
treatment of that condition will result
in the death of of the unborn baby and
even that
is really the sort of double effect it's
not as though a doctor will prescribe
abortion and then that that's the that
is the cure it could be a double effect
though uh for the rest when you hear
about the the risk to the health of the
life of the mother whatever it's just
completely made up it's just that does
not exist okay
so that part is very silly but then of
course even even if there were something
to that
abortion does not save lives every
single abortion kills somebody
every single abortion results in death
but that's the upside down world we're
living in and because the life controls
the means of communication
that's mostly what people hear
because they control big tech because
they control the media because they
control the institutions the
universities that is largely what people
hear and that's how they can be confused
of that
you want to talk about ridiculous
framing terry mcauliffe is this derelict
governor in virginia a real crooked guy
really really crooked and he's facing a
republican challenge from glen younkin
there in virginia so they just had
a they've been debating you know they're
heading into the election and terry
mcauliffe says
that look he's moderate he's not
moderate at all but he says he's
moderate he's got republican support
he's got the support of the leading
conservative in america
guess who it is
i inherited an economy from a republican
governor that had a gigantic deficit and
i left a huge surplus when i left office
and that's the reason why so many
republicans have endorsed me over two
dozen prominent republicans tonight i
have the leading conservative in america
here bill crystal who has endorsed my
campaign for governor
the leading
conservative in america bill crystal
bill crystal is a democrat
he is a registered democrat i believe
right he now he was a republican for a
long time and he worked in the kind of
mostly in the bush world he was involved
in that i actually have kind of an
affection for bill crystal he was a
teacher of mine at a summer fellowship i
did once a very sort of nice guy
but he's he's
it's very difficult to call him a
conservative now he's spent the last
several years campaigning for democrats
promoting rather left-wing policies and
attacking conservatives and republicans
and trying to impede them from winning
elections and getting anything done so
he's just not people can change their
political views all right i don't be
great i'm not saying bill crystal is
just the most evil man walking the earth
right but he's not a conservative he's
not a republican he's a he is now a
liberal democrat in the the end of his
career he's become a liberal democrat
and he spends his time working on
liberal democratic causes and okay
people change their minds doesn't
usually go in that direction but
that's the way it went
that's not the part that bothers me so
much as as terry mcauliffe
saying he's the leading conservative in
america this this is what
a class of republicans exists to do
there is a class of republicans who are
the court jesters in the kingdom of
liberalism and what they do is they they
put up a show a charade of opposition so
it seems like we have a really tough
political system where the two sides are
fighting it out but we don't really we
actually have a dominant ruling
democratic party and then we have some
of their junior partners the the court
jester republicans who go in and they
pretend to fight back but they
ultimately kind of have the same aims
which is why when someone like donald
trump comes along who is offering not
just a different kind of personality but
actually a different set of policies
actually a different political vision
getting tough on trade with our you know
not just having free trade with
everybody getting tough on immigration
not just having open borders right when
donald trump comes along with a
historically much more conservative
much more republican in the old sense of
the word type of platform then all the
court gestures go running
and then they say no this is terrible
this is awful we've got to save our
republic our democracy and they they go
and support the democrats we need real
conservatives there's a there's a great
attack ad right now on one of the real
conservatives out there ron desantis
take a listen to this attack ad tell me
if it if it makes you more or less
likely to vote for ron desantis
ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of your cabin crew we'd like
to inform you that we have officially
entered florida airspace
now that we're making our final descent
please watch this short message from
governor ron desantis on covet 19.
thereafter everyone on board will be
required to comply with the state's
forever purge
we are not doing any vaccine passports
in the state of florida
we trust people to make their own
decisions in this state we are not going
to be bludgeoning people
with restrictions
and mandates
and lockdowns or any of that stuff
as governor desantis stated
while you're within state lines you do
not have to wear a mask
you do not have to get a vaccine
it is against the law for private
businesses or schools to mandate masks
or vaccines
and you have the absolute right to
infect whoever you want whenever and
wherever with covet 19.
no
ron desantis said that he trusts people
to make their own decisions
no
no people can't the fact that someone
would push this out there as an attack
ad
i wouldn't be surprised if ronda santa
secretly funded this to make him look
cooler okay the fact that a group put
this out there and thinks that this is
an attack ad that ron desantis is going
to let people make their own decisions
not have everyone muzzle themselves and
live in fear shows you
just
how radically differently
the two sides see the world in this
country
speaking of
good solid conservatives
senator josh hawley
just came out
with a bill to regulate big tech
i really like this bill this is a good
bill
especially the last few days where big
tech companies notably youtube are
censoring me from stating plain facts
about the coronavirus and the vaccines
facts that are
acknowledged by the director of the cdc
i'm not allowed to do that
because of big tech that is how out of
control they've gotten and in a republic
as i note in my book speechless
in a republic if you control speech you
control the entire political order and
google does that right now google and
youtube which is the same company
they do that right now as does facebook
to a lesser degree as does twitter and
that is unacceptable and i don't care if
they pretend to be private companies
google by the way is not a private
company google is practically an arm of
the government facebook also has
relationships with the government but
regardless regardless
anybody even if they were private
companies
anyone who controls speech in a republic
that's a problem okay that's a big
problem so joshua has this bill it would
remove section 230 protections
from these big tech companies section
230 it's a section of the communications
decency act
which is a law passed in the 1990s had
republican support had democrat support
interestingly people forget this now the
communications decency act aimed at
regulating porn on the internet it was
one of the as the internet was
developing it was there was broad
bipartisan consensus that you could
regulate or limit or even ban porn
outright on the internet and that
wouldn't constitute a first amendment
violation and then some idiot judges
decided that there's nothing more
american than looking at like three
goats and a lady on you know some creepy
website that that therefore we had
couldn't have any regulation of porn
there was another law that republicans
and democrats tried to to put
out also in the 1990s called the child
online protection act same thing had
broad bipartisan support and some idiot
judges shot it down but the part of the
cda
that people are focusing on right now is
section 230 which gives
you know it was just developed at a time
when the internet was very different
than it is today but the effect of it
today is that it gives these big
platforms protection
uh from from
uh prosecution if and civil liability if
there is some kind of uh you know
copyrighted material or obscene material
or things like that because they say
well you can't really control what's on
your platform and so we're going to give
you some protections here you're
different than a newspaper for instance
which is making editorial decisions but
these big tech companies are acting like
newspapers and that they're curating
information limiting who gets to see
what censoring people from stating plain
facts on the platform so it's time for
them to lose those those protections
what hawley's bill would do
is allow
parents to sue social media companies
for quote bodily injury or harm to
mental health of their children that in
whole or in part
that is attributable to the individual's
use of a covered interactive computer
service provided by the social media
company so
part of this comes out because there was
a report that facebook knew that
instagram is damaging to
young people's psychological health and
we all know that we all know that social
media is in in many ways damaging to our
our health psychologically spiritually
what have you and so what what this
would do
is
and facebook kind of covered it up and
didn't care and kept addicting kids to
this stuff
regardless of the reasoning you can give
whatever scientific reasoning you want
i just want i will i will support
basically any bill that reigns in the
power of big tech okay
if you had a bill tomorrow called the
cato bill called the big tech delinda
est bill that said that you know it is
now an act of congress that
big tech's buildings are going to be
seized
knocked to the ground the earth will be
salted where their servers once stood
and we will hear the lamentations and
whaling of their i.t department i would
vote for that bill okay because it is
and by the way i work as as many of us
do these virtually all of us to some
degree works in relation to these social
media companies but i recognize that
this is an actual threat to the republic
to our democracy you always hear so much
about our democracy these guys these
three losers in silicon valley led by
hipster rasputin jack dorsey
but the others as well these these
creeps are out there
limiting what we can say basic
statements the fact that the cdc
director says certain things about
vaccines that we're not allowed to
repeat that is unacceptable and they
need to be punished for that and they
need to have their power taken away from
them and whatever i don't i don't want
to hear any but my liberty but my this
but the unintended i don't want to hear
it the the i don't want to hear about
your hypothetical worries about
something that might happen in the
future
when it is already happening right now
okay i just don't want to hear about it
i want you to fix the problem now and
grow a spine
and then we can deal with the other
problems that come up later
cancel big tech cancel their power at
least that's what we're talking about
speaking of canceling things
this this relates to the breakthrough
the breakthrough cases that keep on
breaking through and they're breaking
through everywhere but they're just
breakthrough cases they're not
evidence of a systemic problem according
to youtube
aladdin is back on broadway aladdin is a
you know based on the disney movie
aladdin is a broadway musical it's been
closed for 18 months it just reopened
and after one night of being reopened
it's been canceled again
because of breakthrough cases
breakthroughs
breakthrough cases
you know if it
if the cases keep on breaking through
maybe we should stop calling them
breakthrough cases maybe we should stop
having such hysterical fears of this
maybe people who are gravely at risk
ought to
take precautions maybe people who are
not really all that at risk should go on
and live their lives and maybe you ought
to all stop living in fear speaking of
these sort of hysterical fears i've got
to cover this
you may have heard last week
there was a racist incident an allegedly
racist incident at parkway central high
school in chesterfield missouri i don't
want you to confuse this there was
another allegedly racist incident at
some other institution this is a
different one but maybe you read about
it somewhere racism
there was racist graffiti found in
multiple bathrooms in the high school
and students took the opportunity to
skip class they staged a walkout
they cursed at the school administrators
people were crying according to the
saint louis post dispatch
the
superintendent wrote he said students
and staff are hurt angry feeling
outnumbered by those who seem willing to
stand by and watch without taking action
to stop it those evil white supremacist
kids not they were attacking the black
oppressed
students
guess who spray-painted the graffiti or
or wrote the graffiti guess who did it
guess who wrote the racist messages
do you think he had blonde hair and blue
eyes you would be wrong
it was a black student it was a hoax
as it seems almost always to be
almost i i outline this in my book
speechless i go through incident after
incident after incident
of these race hoaxes
and then what does one student say a
student says
who participated in the walkout against
the racism that didn't exist yes it was
embarrassing to find out the perpetrator
was black but this didn't change the
message of the protesters and they hoped
that school administrators put in place
a policy to keep these statements from
being made
you hear this all the time well yes the
incident that we're using to justify
these things was a hoax but it gets to a
greater truth no it doesn't it doesn't
it doesn't there's just no
white supremacy
racism
all this stuff that we're told is an
epidemic in america it
barely exists if it exists at all
what does exist is an epidemic of
delusion
fantasy hysteria and a a
true desire
to be able to claim oppression and
victimhood that that's the real virus
and we got a lot more than a lot more
than breakthrough cases okay it's a
widespread
pandemic
you know today you can listen to uh what
happened to freedom land how it became
fantasy land when the elites live in
their imaginations you can listen to
that
andrew's show on the andrew clavin show
so make sure you go check that out and
then we will be right back with the
mailbag
welcome back
to the show my favorite time of the week
the mailbag first question up from aruna
who says dear dr koffe
in
the hindu religion we believe animals
have souls your fellow catholics sheamus
of freedom tunes fame recently commented
that catholics believe that animals
possess souls though of a different
variety than humans could you elaborate
on this yes it's kind of a common
misconception
the catholic view and you know
the broadly christian view though i
think some some protestant denominations
might disagree with this uh is that
animals do have souls it's not that they
don't have souls they do have souls
because the souls are the principle of
life
right they are they are the principle of
life but not all souls are created equal
so while animals possess souls they do
not possess rational souls
right and this this is why when uh you
know your dog urinates on the rug you
might smack him with a newspaper and try
to get him not to do that in the future
but you don't sob to him and try to
convince him of the error of his ways
and explain to him the injustice of
urinating on the carpet because the the
dog doesn't have any conception of
justice the dog doesn't have any
conception at all they're not they're
not capable of conceptual thought
this is why
you know if your dog bites the little
kid in the neighborhood you don't put
him on trial because the dog can't sin
the dog does not has a soul has you know
has the principle of life in him but
does not have
a uh a rational soul and uh that soul is
not
spiritual the soul is material so the
the dog i'm sorry to tell you will not
go to heaven the the when the dog dies
this the dog's soul dies as well human
beings are different we have a rational
soul that is spiritual and spiritual
things you know
go where the spirits are
hope that clears it up from james
michael i'm getting married to a
wonderful woman in a couple of months
she's kind intelligent knows me better
than i know myself is she google is she
facebook no no because she's kind and
intelligent she's relatively
conservative and we agree on 70 or 80 of
issues including general morals and
religion however we recently had a small
fight regarding homosexuals and drag
queens i recently found out she will
have a drag queen at her bachelorette
party and even worse does not think it's
an issue to tell our children gay
marriage is equal to normal marriage
this is insane and could lead to
confusion in our future children how do
i effectively communicate the reasons
why this is the case constructively and
convincingly james future virginian yeah
look i mean your wife sounds great your
fiance sounds great but she's
while she's rejected quite a lot of the
dominant culture she seems to have still
been brought along by some trappings of
the dominant culture
forget a second the homosexuals and the
drag queens even the idea of a
bachelorette party is just i know this
is going to be an unpopular opinion it's
feminist nonsense it's just complete
claptrap the whole point of a bachelor
party is that men have to kind of be
dragged into getting married because men
you know kind of enjoy being single they
put off getting married very often and
so it's the last hurrah and then the men
are going to get married and hopefully
reform and shape up and the women are
going to civilize them and they're going
to have a good family life for the rest
of their lives
men do not
dream about their wedding day from the
time that they're little boys okay they
don't start writing you know i'll be
mister
michael knowles because we don't change
her name so but we're not oh yes and i'm
you know drawing little pictures of
yourself at your wedding day and no we
don't do that it's just because men and
women are different women do that women
do fantasize about their their wedding
day from a very young age women do want
to get married in a way that's different
than men they generally don't need to be
dragged kicking and screaming into it
and so the idea that women need that one
last hurrah they need to go out and look
at a bunch of i don't know male
strippers or something go get hammered
at the bar it just
i'm not saying there aren't exceptions
but women generally don't relate to sex
and alcohol quite in that way and they
certainly don't relate to those things
in the same way that that men do
because they're different i know this is
shocking so it just seems to me that
your wife's fallen into this trap of yes
every woman needs a bachelor party
bachelorette party because men and women
are the same and yeah we need to do fun
stuff so we're not gonna go to a strip
club because we don't actually like that
but we're gonna have a drag queen isn't
that gonna be wild and transgressive and
crazy and weird okay we're gonna do that
and you know even on the point of
redefining marriage i mean i think you
can just explain to her that
we value homosexuals and think they all
have equal dignity before god and you
know our children of god but marriage
has a meaning and and it doesn't
marriage has something to do with sexual
difference and your your wife just seems
to
probably through no fault of her own
have imbibed a lot of the modern
cultures
nonsense that men and women are the same
and they're not the same and so you know
i would just clear that up but i don't
think you need to call off your wedding
it sounds like you guys are basically on
the same page and you know lead your
family you'll be the head of your
household and i think it'll be all right
from tony dear mr knowles
i'm currently an employee at a federal
contractor and with the supreme dictator
biden's vaccine mandate the company is
forcing me to get vast barring a
religious exemption or disability
exemption i don't have a disability and
with pope francis's stance and the
bishop stance on morality of the
vaccines i'm not likely to get a
religious exemption either i don't want
to lose my job especially since i don't
have any good leads for an alternative
career path but i have serious questions
about the experimental drug adding to
the complexity of the situation is the
fact that my last living grandparent
won't see me
uh i won't let me see her again unless i
get the jab i feel trapped between a
rock and a hard place what should i do
sincerely a fellow sicilian drag
catholic ps thank you for your work it
always leaves me speechless thank you
sir appreciate it so let's put aside for
a second what your job is telling you to
do
to me and everything and let's also
remember i i'm not of the opinion
that
getting the shot or not getting the shot
is the make or break issue for your
political identity or something i i
don't see the reason that a great
majority of people even should get the
shot i don't see why young and healthy
people should get the shot i just don't
agree with the arguments that people
make for that and i don't agree
with the protestations that there are no
questions whatsoever about the vaccine
and i mean the cdc and the fda have
admitted that there are certain side
effects they had to pause one of the
vaccines because of that
so
i i
i think that this is a prudential matter
okay
and i think you ought to if you don't
want to get it and you don't think that
you're greatly at risk you ought to
resist it as best you can
and i know that we none of us want to be
bullied into this especially by you know
old pudding head there in the white
house
but
the second reason you gave to me is the
better one
your last living grandparent doesn't
want to see you unless you get the shot
and you can explain until you're blue in
the face that
you're getting vaccinated or not really
doesn't have anything to do with your
last living grandparent because you're
presumably at least what we're told by
the public health authorities is that
your vaccine the individual's vaccine
will protect the individual from getting
uh hospitalization or a risk of dying so
whether or not you're vaccinated is kind
of beside the point but that doesn't
matter the fact is you want to see your
last living grandparent before that last
time and grandparent dies and so
would you take a risk to be able to see
your grandparent as an act of love and
filial piety i mean i i would strongly
consider that
much more than i would
the uh
the biden mandate you know if the biden
mandate if anything i think would make
everybody say nope ain't doing this
sorry and so
i know that's not a satisfying
ideological answer but do you want to
say your grandparent or not
i don't know you know and to me that of
all the arguments i've heard for why
people should get the shot i think most
of them are kind of bogus and i think
you should just
resist them uh but that that one is
maybe the most compelling one i've heard
so uh you know it's too bad it's
unfortunate doesn't mean that you have
to know ascent to say that the shot is
great or that everyone should get it or
the mandates are good or anything like
that but i i understand the personal
aspect here you want to see your
grandparent okay
that would weigh heavily in in my
prudential thinking at least if i were
in your position from marisa hey michael
hate to be a broken record but i'm
struggling with manifesting oh my
goodness man if we brought this up on
the show we didn't bring it up someone
brought it up in the mailbag this is
this new age religion
that if you just think positive thoughts
and think of things that you want to
have that you can force
god to give them to you basically that's
the kind of the idea um so uh
marissa goes on i have friends who keep
encouraging me to do it again and they
claim they're happier less anxious and
have had great things come into their
lives by focusing on certain things and
doing affirmations daily honestly i was
less stressed and had good things happen
while i was visualizing and focused on
what i wanted how can i feel that same
way and have good things happen without
acting as a god who thinks they can
manipulate the world around me it's so
tempting to feel more at ease and have
that consistent inner peace i'm talking
more about feeling content and focusing
on the things i want from my life rather
than giving into base desires of
pleasure maybe doing affirmations and
focusing and visualizing isn't actually
the new age religion and manifesting if
it makes you happy it can't be that bad
right i don't know there are plenty of
things i did in college that made me
happy for a time that i don't don't
think very highly of and that i regret
and i think they probably were that bad
so i think that's true for probably most
of us out there so
uh no
manifesting is very bad don't do it
it is a kooky new age religion it is
heretical it's sacrilegious it's making
demands of god which is something we're
told not to do and it can open yourself
up in the spiritual level to really bad
stuff it also will leave you
psychologically distraught because the
the premise here
is that if as long as you think
positively enough as long as you do
enough
all good things will happen to you and
bad things won't happen to you and one
of the real problems with this is that
when bad things do inevitably happen to
you then it's your fault then you have
no one to blame but yourself a lot of
the prosperity gospel type people who
are another
version of heretics this they can be
nice people and they can smile a lot and
make you feel good about yourself for a
time this is the problem with them
because the rain falls on the just and
the unjust alike this is what the book
of job is about right this is god saying
that
it's not just that good people get good
things and bad people get bad things in
this world
that actually very very good people can
have very very bad things happen to them
and often do and in in the history of
the world by the way the very best
people have had the very worst things
happen to them
right the saints christ himself i mean
the greatest example the passion and the
and the crucifixion
the very best person who has ever walked
the earth had the very worst thing
happened to him
so
you're you're trying to find some peace
and you're trying to find peace in the
optimism that good things will happen to
you if you do certain things i think you
might find peace in the optimism that
very bad things will happen they will
happen inevitably and it doesn't say
anything about your
virtue necessarily it doesn't say
anything about your piety necessarily it
doesn't say anything about your
salvation necessarily i think there is
far greater peace and far greater truth
in the fact that the rain will fall on
the just and the unjust alike than in
whatever kooky claptrap some new age
witches are trying to sell you from
andrew hey michael i do not pretend to
be a knower of all things however since
i have a curious mind i'd like to know
your opinion on the following according
to google the average person expels 2.3
pounds of carbon dioxide per day
on average one cigarette contains 1.22
grams of carbon dioxide
converted to pounds that would be
0.00268964
dividing respectively that would mean
you would need to smoke
855.15 cigarettes or about 45 packs per
day to achieve the same co2 level if
smoking is bad so is prolonged mask
wearing hashtag trust the science
you know you may have taken some
liberties there in that scientific
analysis
but certainly no more than dr fauci has
you know i i would say i trust you on
science at least as much as i trust dr
fauci from camille
thank camille you've written him before
thank you for taking on the role of my
dating coach yep that's the same camille
i got another one for you i was watching
tik tok recently yes i know i too hate
myself perhaps that's why i'm still
single anyway anyway i saw a video of a
woman that said it doesn't matter what
guy you meet it's all about whether or
not he's ready for a relationship is
that true is it really only about timing
that's not a very romantic way to view
life so hopefully it's not the case as
always we'd love to know your opinions
sincerely tick tock on the clock no some
some men are better men than others and
are better formed and better educated
and have better intentions and fewer
vices and
a better sense of the world than others
and they at a great many times would be
good to meet
and uh some of the men that you may have
met camille would be bad to me at any
time as well
now
many people
many of the good guys that you meet you
know people you would say are good guys
have been bad guys in the past i would
say most of them if not all of them
and they've repented and they've kind of
reformed and changed their lives and
gotten a better handling on things so in
that case timing really does matter the
case of age timing really does matter so
i do think it's both of these things but
i don't i'm going to modify some of my
advice i gave to another frequent writer
into the show nick who says that you
know i told nick to go out throw a stick
and marry the first person he finds
because he's getting too trapped into
dating life well for you i would temper
some of that advice and say it's not
just about any guy you find as long as
the timing is right the guy
actually does matter and i think you can
it might be hard but you can probably
still find a good guy out there i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show i'll see you on monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2021. hey
everybody this is andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin